marie kamara is 16 years old and wanted
to be a nurse
but the coronavirus pandemic pushed her
family into poverty
she says she had little choice but to
leave school and marry instead
they would tell them when he went to
meet my parents they called me and asked
me about his proposal
and i told them you have no money to
send me to school
so let me get married
marie's stepfather runs a tailoring shop
in como in eastern sierra leone
he's had few customers this year because
of the pandemic
marie's husband is in his mid-twenties
and offered to provide rice for her
younger sisters and access to his
watering hole
as part of his marriage proposal the
past two months still
with me the past months have been hard
for me it's been difficult to afford
enough food
i don't have money people don't come to
buy from my business because of this
pandemic
the un defines child marriage as a
marriage of a girl or boy before the
age of 18. and it says the number of
girls getting married in sierra leone
before that age
dropped from 56 percent in 2006
to 39 10 years later but when schools
closed in march
child marriage rates surged
activists say many of the girls mothers
were themselves married off as teenagers
and see child marriage as normal they do
not see it as
harming their children for them it's
probably like
this is possibly one of the better
investments and better things that i
could do for my child
it's a mindset that sierra leone's first
lady is working to change with her
campaign
called hands off our girls a child
doesn't give consent to sex
so if you if you force a child
to be married at a very early age you
are legalizing rape on that child
and that has been our campaign schools
reopened in sierra leone two months ago
but the impact of covid19 means many
girls
may never go back to the classroom
victoria gatenbee al jazeera